my dad
pat senior you're calling ps1 he's a
three-time pro bowler 12-year vet
this is my dog pat certain ii first-team
all-american
so he's a national champ also we're real
life superheroes like jupiter's legacy
and that's no cap
no kizzy
i would say my dad i think just watching
him play i think it inspired me to play
you know throughout the course of my
years i had a bunch of
uncles and cousins who who played in in
high school
and just just growing up in new orleans
you know that was just a way of living
guys just played football you know all
day every day
and i coached them throughout high
school so just a special bond
that we have you know just being out
there it was a privilege coaching my son
oh and what would daddy think
in the man-to-man challenge against my
dad i went because i got the
the younger bones the um he's getting
old am i nervous
no i never get nervous it's competition
competition brings out the best of me he
may get me
but i ain't nervous
got two shoes on man
he'll put a hamstring i think i win this
dude's strong man
big strong and fast so i'm pushing 45
that's dog years in football years so
i give them this one why aren't you over
there helping
you kidding me i got flaming fish
oh yeah i'm winning i'm winning for sure
my hand's certified i don't need no
gloves
so
[Music]
remember i got 37 picks in the league
oh
give me give me the same balls i gave
you you gonna drop one right here
[Music]
oh come on q.b
[Music]
this is what i
he's do man he's throwing it right down
the middle
he got me about one we already talked
about who was a former quarterback
so i gave him perfect balls too many
spirals going on there i could have been
a quarterback too we're gonna definitely
have to get a rematch though you know i
don't go down easy like that
he took the easy way out did that look
easy to you
sheldon go you'll wait for me at the
union
[Music]
oh damn
[Music]
no wait no way my drone had to be longer
my we tied it we tied
he dotted my arm though so i had to show
him a little song i haven't seen him
throwing the minute he shocked me
the certain legacy is just being a
family man being a child of god
you know being being a mentor to so many
he's going to go into the league this
year and carry that legacy
the search hand legacy just means more
than just football it means more to life
and everything
after that football love and power are
definitely part of the certain legacy